When we think about Grant's situation with his suitcase, x can really only equal
a whole number. Remember that x stood for the number of wiper sets that Grant
has packed in his suitcase. And since wiper sets are objects in the world,
they're countable things. You can't really have half of a wiper set, or I guess
you could, but Grant's only taking complete sets with him. Now, when I say that
wiper sets can be counted, you might automatically think of the natural numbers.
Since these are the counting numbers, 1, 2, 3, 4 and so on. But in principle,
Grant could also pack zero glasses wipers. He could just not bring any wipers to
the expo, probably wouldn't be that smart, but he could do it. And if we take
this set of natural numbers and add zero to it, we get the whole numbers.